i think the way we pulled out could not
have been worse a sense of betrayal not
just in afghanistan but america too
james is a former u.s soldier for almost
two years his team was helped by an
afghan interpreter nicknamed rambo he
ate with them climbed mountains with
them and fought the war with them but
now the time to repay that loyalty has
arrived america's chaotic exit from
afghanistan has put those promises made
to rambo in peril the last few days has
been a failure in leadership
a failure in planning
a failure of intelligence
and just a failure a failure of of doing
the right thing and that's why my friend
is sitting in his house right now
terrified to go outside
rambo has asked for his voice to be
changed he's hiding at home his
neighbors know he worked with the
americans and he fears he will be given
up to the taliban they're walking around
every street there's kind of scary
situation here
if he can hear that if anybody
can hear our sound please help us don't
leave us behind rambo is one of
thousands of afghans trying to find a
way out under this new regime he knows
time is running out like these people he
doesn't trust that this is a different
brand of taliban
desperation etched on the faces of 640
men women and children crammed onto this
u.s air force jet seizing their
opportunity to escape
president biden has promised to help
afghan citizens evacuate but he's been
on holiday at his camp david country
retreat leaving his national security
adviser to address what happens when the
time for complete withdrawal comes we're
speaking to afghan citizens who
supported the american mission in
afghanistan who are now terrified for
their lives can you confirm that when it
gets to august 31st and your troops
leave will you abandon them or will you
stay and save them
our plan is to
safely evacuate
the people who worked with the united
states who are eligible for special
immigrant visas which is a generous
program set up on a bipartisan basis by
our our congress we have identified
those individuals and families we are
making provision to have them come to
the airport and get on evacuation
flights out of the country
for a president usually ruled by empathy
joe biden has taken a cold-eyed approach
to this exit but his foreign policy
legacy could now be defined by what
happens to the afghans who fear they're
being left behind martha kellner sky
news washington